Speaker 1: All right. This story is really
interesting. So yesterday, Joe Biden called
Fox News reporter Peter do see a stupid son
of a bitch. Some people say it was a hot mike
that Joe Biden didn't know his mike was on.
It's not obvious to me. I when you watched
the video, when you listen, Biden's face is
right in front of a microphone. And I think
it's quite plausible. Biden did know that
the mike was on, and it's sort of like slipped
out or he just didn't care or whatever. And
the incident itself is not that interesting
to me. But the reaction is absolutely fascinating
because of the incredible hypocrisy that Republicans
are applying. So here's the backstory. Steve
Doocy is in the press corps for Fox News.
His big thing is constantly trying to ask
gotcha questions of Jen Psaki and of Joe Biden.
They're often very stupid, but it doesn't
really matter. Joe Biden calls on Peter Do
see all the time it's known. Everybody knows
Doocy is going to ask adversarial questions.
Joe Biden calls on him all the time. He hasn't
tried to get him kicked out of the press corps.
He hasn't tried to get his credential removed
the way Donald Trump did of Jim Acosta and
others. And so yesterday, as Steve, as Peter
Doocy often does, he yelled a question to
Joe Biden. The question was, is it a liability
to have high inflation? And Biden sort of
responded. No, it's an asset sarcastically
and said, You stupid son of a bitch. So let's
look. Here's the video and here's the audio.
Unidentified: Peter n.a. n.a. n.a. n.a. n.a.
n.a. n.a.
Speaker 2: n.a. n.a. n.a. n.a. n.a.. My First
Political. That's a great asset. More inflation.
Unidentified: What a stupid sermon. OK.
Speaker 1: What a stupid son of a bitch. So
let's go through this. Is is do so we're going
to get to Glenn Greenwald in a second is do
seem more or less a moron. Yeah, his his,
you know, bogus gotcha questions. They're
just so boring at this point. They're gotchas,
but they fail. Now, Joe Biden was out of line
when it comes to decorum. This is not how
a president should speak to members of the
press. I agree with the assessment of Doocy
as basically being a moron. He's annoying.
He's just trying to get gotcha and sound bites
and whatever. But when I would criticize Donald
Trump and say, that's not how you should be
treating members of the press, I apply the
exact same standard to Joe Biden. Biden was
out of line. Presidents shouldn't speak like
this, even if it was funny, even if it was
fun, even if it was a higher energy moment
for Biden. Whatever. OK, so fine. It should
not have spoken that way. That being said,
there are people taking this incident to suggest
that the sky is falling and that this is a
dangerous attack on press freedom. One example
is a guy named Glenn Greenwald. Glenn Glenn
Greenwald used to do some pretty good reporting
back in the day that a lot of interesting
stuff. But now I don't know what is going
on with Glenn Greenwald. Check out this is
a very somber Greenwald reporting to us that
it is a very dark, dark day in America because
of what Joe Biden said. Check this out.
Speaker 4: Hello, everyone, this is Glenn
Greenwald, and today is a dark and really
dangerous day for press freedom in America,
a hard working journalist, Peter Doocy, did
nothing more than go to work today to do his
job. He went to the White House to ask a question
of the most powerful political official on
the planet President Biden a question, and
this is the assault that was unleashed on
him.
Speaker 1: OK, so then he plays. That was
it was an assault. This is some of the fakest
drama that I can imagine here. Here's the
bottom line, OK? Biden was out of line with
Peter Doocy, without a doubt, the people saying
this was a dangerous attack on freedom of
the press, that this was an assault when there
has been no contempt for the media from Joe
Biden during his presidency. These very same
people, I'm not talking about Glenn Greenwald
now, but the people look at Twitter, right?
The very same people losing their minds over
what Joe Biden said were silent during the
Trump administration. When Trump mocked a
disabled reporter, they were silent when Trump
attacked Jim Acosta and had him banned, and
when he called Chuck Todd a bitch and all
these different things. Biden was out of line,
but Biden called Doocy to apologize. Trump
never apologized to the reporters he mistreated.
Look at how Peter Doocy even describes the
conversation
Speaker 5: after years of clips of the president,
and I kind of mixing it up on the campaign
trail and during the transition and here at
the White House. Within about an hour of that
exchange, he called my cell phone and he said,
It's nothing personal, pal. And we went back
and forth and we were talking about. I just
kind of moving moving forward, and I made
sure to tell him that I'm always going to
try to ask something different than what everybody
else is asking. And he said, You've got to.
And that's a quote from the president.
Speaker 1: Does that sound like Donald Trump?
Does that prove to us that this was a dark
and dangerous day in America? No. Come on,
guys. Biden immediately apologized. Trump
would never apologize. Biden has never advocated
for, nor has he tried to ban Peter Doocy from
the press briefings. In fact, he calls on
him almost every briefing Trump took away.
Jim Acosta's press credential. Joe Biden has
never broadly called adversarial media the
enemy of the people. He's never called the
media the enemy of the people. Trump called
the the enemy, referred to adversarial media
as the enemy of the people. There is no similarity
between this and Trump. Biden was out of line.
I apply the same standard to Biden and Trump
on how they talk to members of the media.
Biden apologized. And everything about the
context is completely different. Give me a
break, guys. It's hard to even take seriously
the videos like that from Glenn Greenwald
when what the relationship has been with the
Biden administration in the media is 180 degrees
different from what it was under Trump. If
you disagree with me, let me know. But it's
it's just pathetic opportunism that we are
seeing here.